President Biden and House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy have reached a deal
to raise the debt limit.
And now they are racing
to convince lawmakers
on both sides of the aisle
to back the plan.
The House is set to vote on the deal
just two days from now.
What do you say to members
of your own party
who say you need
to make concessions in this deal?
Well, find
I didn't think you're going
to get a majority of Republicans
voting for this bill.
This is a good bill
for the American public.
The president agreed with this bill.
So I think there's going to be
a lot of Democrats
are going to vote for two.
And the House Progressive Caucus already
speaking out against new work
requirements in the deal
for food stamp recipients.
It is
really unfortunate
that the president
opened the door to this.
And while at the end of the day,
perhaps this will
because of the exemptions,
perhaps it will be okay.
I can't commit to that.
I really don't know.
And the conservative House Freedom
Caucus also
pushing back against the deal, saying
it does not cut enough spending.
Some key members
tweeted, no Republican capitulation
and hold the line.
As for the debt ceiling,
the latest warning
from Treasury Secretary Janet Yellen
estimates that the government
could run out of money
to pay
all of its debts on time,
the so-called X date on June 5th.
One week from today,
CNN chief correspondent Manu Raju
live for us on Capitol Hill. So, Manu.
For those of us
just waking up on a Monday morning
who may not have been following
the Saturday and Sunday
break, the deal for us
Yeah, look, this was a hard
fought negotiation and negotiation
that the White House didn't
want to have to begin with.
Remember President Biden
for about three months,
more than three months,
just refused to sit down
with Kevin McCarthy
because he demanded the debt ceiling
be increased,
$31.4 trillion debt ceiling be increased
without any conditions,
without any spending cuts.
Warning that averting
trying to do
so would avert a fiscal disaster here.
But Kevin
McCarthy had a different approach.
He demanded
spending cuts,
a whole slew of conditions.
Ultimately,
the White House was forced to negotiate
and make a range of concessions
that is angering both sides of the aisle.
Some liberals upset
and also some conservatives upset
with the deal that McCarthy cut.
Now, a little bit about the deal,
two year
suspension of the debt limit
essentially would expire
in January of 20.
25 That is got some concern on the right
they believe that
it should have only been one year
for allowing them
preventing them from fighting this again
next year in an election year
also to ensure
that veterans and medical care
is not impacted by the spending cuts
that would have happened across the board
on domestic programs.
There's essentially a
for defense programs
there's not a cut for defense
but that's caused some concerns
among defense hawks who believe that
that is not
they need to have more money
for the Pentagon.
So expect some pushback
from the right on that.
But that's also
it would expand work requirements
for food stamp recipients.
That has caused a lot of angst
among on the left.
And it has a whole host of other issues,
such as cutting IRS funding
that's caused some concern
among Democrats,
as well as rescinding unspent Kobani
that actually had some bipartisan support
as part of this deal.
And one thing to watch that actually
could generate
some opposition from progressives
is that it
would actually expedite construction
of a pipeline
in West Virginia, a big priority
for West Virginia Senator Joe Manchin.
But something
that progressives in particular
were upset about.
Now, what the White House has been trying
to tell Democrats
what they did last night
in all these two briefings
with the House and Senate Democrats
was they could have been a lot worse.
One of the things that
did not make it in
this bill was to impose
new work requirements
for recipients of the Medicaid health
insurance program
because it's a low income health
care program.
Republicans had pushed for new work
requirements for those recipients
that did not get in the bill.
They also argued
a whole host of other issues,
such as the president's
signature inflation
reduction Act, was not cut
as Republicans had pushed for,
which is what they're trying to convince
Democrats.
This is the best
we can get,
even as a lot of folks
on the right saying
those cuts should have been imposed
and McCarthy should have demanded more
and should not have given the president.
And as long
the debt
limits expansion
as it's in this current deal,
causing a lot of angst
on both wings of the party
as they try to get this to Congress,
a lot of angst,
a lot of unpredictability moneywise you.
Thank you.
We shall see. Yes, we will.
I want to bring in
now CNN economics commentator
and Washington Post
opinion columnist Catherine Rampell
and former Democratic congressman
from New York, Max Rose, who's also,
of course, a veteran of the war
in Afghanistan.
He received a Purple Heart,
among other honors.
Nice to see you both this morning.
I'm going to start with you.
When we look at what's happening here
and I think,
you know, as Manu laid out for us,
we know there's a lot of skepticism.
There's a lot of angst
on both sides of the aisle here.
But we pressed people a lot
and we say, I need a yes or no answer,
as you know all too well.
And Congresswoman Jayapal actually
gave Jake Tapper a one word answer
when he said,
does the president
basically need to be worried here?
And she said, yes,
you should be worried about progressives
if the White House messaging is, hey,
it could have been worse.
Is that really enough
to convince progressives
it will be enough for it to pass?
It will not be enough
to convince progressives.
So you have this incredibly
fascinating dynamic right now where
Kevin McCarthy and Joe Biden
and potentially
also the leader
of the Democratic caucus, Hakeem
Jeffries, will all be working in tandem
together
to pass this legislation,
of course, to avoid economic catastrophe,
but also because it is in their political
best interests now with this bill,
the administration has certainly cemented
the fact that it is absolutely,
resolutely committed
to bipartisanship and normalcy
And in the process,
I actually think
that they have boxed
the Republican Party
into this really awful corner
where by now
the Republican Party has to advocate
for increased spending.
Of course,
because the debt ceiling will be raised
by trillions of dollars
and for increased social service
spending.
Now, with an expansion of SNAP benefits,
for veterans as well as the homeless.
On the other hand,
the Republican Party can say
the Democratic Party
did not get any of their priorities
in there and that, yes, is true as well.
So it might be the sign
of a great negotiation
that nobody is happy right now,
but this will
certainly pass will pass
because of moderates
on both sides of the aisle.
And they will largely do that
because they do not want to be the reason
for economic calamity.
Catherine,
let me bring you into the conversation,
because there's been a lot of drama.
There's been a lot of noise.
And you say in a recent op ed
that there has already been
some harm done,
even if we don't actually default.
Yes.
Look, I look at this deal and say
how is it any different than what
we would have
reasonably expect
to get from the usual annual
appropriations process?
It's really not that different
given divided government Republicans
didn't get the draconian cuts
that they asked for.
They didn't get
the Medicaid work requirements.
They didn't get some of the other things
that I was worried about,
including basically
undermining the entire regulatory state.
They basically got flat spending,
which, again, is
what I would have expected
coming out of the appropriations process.
So the question is fine,
but what was it all for?
Right.
We've gone through all of this drama.
We've gone through
economic turmoil,
basically embarrassing ourselves
on the world stage.
Biden having to cut his Asia trip short.
The G-7 kind of being overshadowed
by all of this.
Not to mention probably
higher borrowing costs
as a result of some market stresses.
And we ended up where we would have been
had this whole brinksmanship
episode never happened.
So on the one hand, I'm glad
that we knock on wood,
you know, don't look like we're
about to have a financial apocalypse
and we and that Republicans
didn't get all these other things in.
But like what was the point?
We could have avoided all of this.
Catherine, you and I have talked about
in passing actually here at CNN, your
how you feel about IRS reform.
And I'm curious
what you think about the concessions
that looks like the IRS reform
will receive as part of this bill.
I mean,
do you think it would be significant?
Well,
they're cutting about
a quarter of the funding
that was
appropriated to the IRS last year,
which I think is actually
quite a bad thing.
That money has a huge
return on investment,
both because it means better
customer services
and taxpayers are happier
and they're more voluntarily compliant.
And it means that
the IRS has the resources to go after
wealthy tax cheats and corporations
So I don't think this was a good place
to cut money.
In fact, it will expand deficits.
That said, you know,
they did some kind of accounting gimmicks
where it doesn't look like
it's materially
going to affect the irises
overall in the
near term,
it'll probably be more of a problem
several years from now.
But again, it's it's not making it easier
for rich people to cheat on their taxes.
Doesn't seem like the thing you would do
if you really cared
about getting deficits under control.
Interesting, though,
that will undoubtedly
be put forth
as a win for Republicans
if they got some of that money back.
How does this play to your point
of, look,
if everybody's unhappy that
I guess
this is a good negotiation, right?
Because nobody comes out the winner here,
but how do you sell that to constituents?
Well, there's a few major hurdles here
just in terms
of selling it to legislators.
First of all,
Kevin McCarthy has to get over half
of his own caucus to support this
before it even gets to the floor.
And they have not confirmed
that they will do this.
And that will be in process
as it's known.
Behind the scenes is not fact-based.
This at this point
will be deeply personal.
The speaker wants this.
The leader wants this.
The president wants this.
Get in line
or else there's going to be consequences
down the road that you can't take
the politics out of politics.
McCarthy is doing that
because typically Republicans
have done a very good job
of getting their their caucus
to fall in line.
We are seeing something
a little bit
different here,
which certainly we saw play out
when he was trying to get that gavel.
Sure, sure.
So he
he will be fine at getting,
I believe, more than 50%
because you've already seen leaders
in the moderate wing of that party.
I wouldn't call the moderate.
Let's just say less extreme
wing of that party
expressing their support for this.
With that being said, though,
you know, the Democratic Party,
I think that in that whipping process
that we're seeing right now,
what people will be upset by.
Yes.
Is the policy,
but they're going to be more upset
legislators to be more upset
about two other things. One.
Did we get anything out of this at all?
Our own priorities, Democratic
core Democratic priorities.
They got victories.
What did we get?
But secondly,
I think that there will be certain
angst around giving Kevin McCarthy a win.
So they're going to want to see
the Republicans
show momentum around the show
that they can pass this themselves
or come somewhat close to it
before Democrats
start raising their hands and saying that
that they'll go about doing this.
And of course,
last to conclude,
there's going to be folks,
I want to turn this
into a Christmas tree as well.
I certainly wouldn't rule out
some people thinking about amendments.
How can I get my little appropriation
associated with that?
You'll see a lot of that over
the coming days. That shouldn't happen.